hi this is swagpa from postdeck korea
in this presentation i will introduce
our new domain channelization method
using web cloud images
it's a joint work with my students from
post-tech damiop and taeyeon and dr lan
and professor jung from microsoft
research asia
the problem in this work is synthetic to
real domain generalization for semantic
segmentation
where using synthetic data generated by
3d rendering
we aim to learn semantic segmentation
networks
that well generalize to any arbitrary
real domains latent in training
this task is challenging due to the
substantial appearance gap between the
source and target domains
moreover the learned model should work
well on multiple target domains with
substantial appearance variations due to
different geolocation weather conditions
dates and times and for example
further we have no access to target
domains during training so we have to
learn networks that well generalized to
multiple unseen domains using only
synthetic images
there are a few existing methods for
this challenging task
a pioneering work randomly style
randomly stylizes synthetic training
images using a subset of the image in a
data set as a style sources
segmentation models trained with such
stylized images could be styled in
variant
thus they are better generalized to
target domains whose styles are unknown
on the other hand a follow-up research
encourages the representation learned
using genetic images to be similar with
those of an image in a pre-trained
network
to prepare to prevent the learned
representation from being biased to
synthetic styles of training images
however the first method requires a very
expensive stylization technique like
cyclogen
and the style sources from the image net
often do not reflect the target
application scenarios like autonomous
driving
the second one is also limited by the
knowledge of the imagenet dataset which
provides a only a narrow variation of
natural images
and could be irrelevant to the target
task as well
to overcome these limitations we prep
represent a web image assisted domain
generalization method
wedge
our method consists of three steps
in the first step it cross web images
with search keywords relevant to the
target task
so that the collected images are test
relevant as well as
realistic more importantly the crawled
images exhibit a large variety of real
image styles that potentially cover
latent testing domains
thus they as style sources may help
segmentation models virtually experience
unseen target domains
in the second step
wedge trains a segmentation model with
the synthetic data and their grantor's
labels
while injecting styles of the web images
on the fly
to be specific we replace neural styles
of intermediate convolutional feature
maps of synthetic training images
with
those of web images
during feed food propagation of the
style of synthetic images
this gives illusions of diverse real
images while learning segmentation
models using synthetic data
also for reliable efficient and underfly
style transfer we introduce a style
injection algorithm
in the last step
the web images are used directly for
training as well as post stylization
to this end the model trend in the
second step is applied to the web images
for generating their pseudo-segmentation
labels
this step enhances generalization
capability of the segmentation models by
learning them directly on real images
let me introduce a bit more details of
this of each step so in the first step
where to cross images on flickr using
the search keyword driving and road
since our target application scenario is
autonomous driving
as a result it collected more than 4000
images with cc0 licenses
using these web images
has several advantages since
they they provide a variety of real
image styles that potentially cover
target domains
and are more relevant to the tag task
than those in the imaging data set
and
let me introduce
the details of the style injection
in the second step of wet
a neural style of an image is here
represented by channel wise mean and
standard division of activations in a
particular intermediate feature map
and the style injection is implemented
by first whitening the activations of
synthetic images using their mean and
standard deviation and then translating
and scaling them with the mean and
standard deviation of activations of a
web crawled images
this process is applied to multiple
layers of segmentation networks
also its non-parametric nature and low
computation cost enables fast and
on-the-fly style manipulation
and by focusing more on styles and
disregarding contents of web images
the style injection module allows
allows us to reliably utilize web images
even when their contents are not
relevant to the target task
finally
in the third step
wedge generates pseudo labels of the web
images by applying the model in the
second step
note that the pseudo labels disregarded
disregard pixels whose predictions are
unreliable
to alleviate the negative impact of
errors in the pseudolabels
then wedge it trains the segmentation
model obtained in the second step
further by using the web images as well
as the synthetic ones as training data
we first quantitatively compare our
method with the previous work on domain
generalization
in this experiment
the models are trained on the gta 5 data
the synthetic dataset and tested on
three real image data sets cityscapes
bdds and bapillary
we also evaluate their performance while
bearing the backbone architecture of
their segmentation networks
be seen in this table our method
outperforms all the competitors in every
combination of backbone and tested data
set
wedges is also compared with previous
work
in terms of domain generalization from
another synthetic data set called
cynthia to the three real world imagery
data set
in this experiment also our method beats
the previous work completely
and these are qualitative results of our
method
here the baseline indicates the same
segmentation network trained only on the
synthetic data set without considering
domain generalization
as shown in this figure
our method segments images accurately
in in spite of the large appearance you
get between the synthetic training and
real testing data
also the style injection in the second
step
substantially improve the performance
although adding the third step further
enhances the quality of segmentation by
empirically removing vast positives of
object classes
we also provide in-depth analysis on our
method to better illustrate
contributions of each component
first we investigate the impact of using
task relevant web images
to this end we trained variance of wedge
that utilizes image net images or
web images cloud by the keyword indoor
which simulates the images totally
relevant to the target application
our method outperforms all these
variants which suggests that our
crawling process is useful and the task
relevance of style sources matters
we can also see that
the style injection allows to use style
source images of irrelevant content
reliably
in addition to demonstrate the advantage
of the style injection over the style
invariant representation learning
our method is compared with adapt output
which is a domain adversary learning
strategy
and our method significantly
outperformed the previous work in our
domain generalization setting
finally the impact of the number of web
images used in
our method is verified by evaluating
performance while bearing the number of
web images using the method
this graph
shows that the generalization capability
of wedge has been improved substantially
by using only 1000 web images
but using the whole web images further
improve the performance
okay
in summary
our method is the first attempt to
utilize web images for domain
generalization of semantic segmentation
and the style injection enables to learn
semantic segmentation
using only styles of web images
efficiently effectively and reliably
and by using the web images and their
pseudolabels as training data we can
further improve the generalization
capability of the learned models
and as a consequence our method
outperforms all the existing techniques
for domain generalizable semantic
segmentation in every setting
thank you for your attention
hello my name is chong lo i am a
principal researcher with the
intelligent multimedia group of msra
today i'm going to talk about pre-text
task design for unsupervised video
representation learning
the title is a bit long let's start with
the keyword video representation
learning or vrl for short
the task of vil in deep learning era is
to train a neural network which takes a
short clip of video as input and produce
a feature embedding that could be used
in a variety of downstream tasks
the process to train the model is
usually called pre-training
and the learning task used in the
pre-training is called pre-text task
the key components in video pre-training
are backbone network design and pre-text
design
in this talk i will focus the discussion
on pre-text design
in self-supervised learning where human
annotations are not available pre-text
tasks can be classified as
reconstruction-based
transformation-based contrastive
learning-based or a combination of the
above
in this talk i will briefly review some
of the existing work and then introduce
one piece of our recent work which
brings pretext design down to the object
level instead of frame or clip level
the basic idea behind reconstruction
based pre-text design is to reconstruct
the video frames or specific features of
the video
now we already know that
reconstructing pixel values or very
specific features such as histograms are
not necessary nor efficient because the
network will be trained to focus too
much on low-level details instead of
global semantics
another interesting type of pre-text
task is transformation based
the input video clips are intentionally
manipulated such as being rotated or
temporarily shuffled and the network is
trained to predict what kind of
manipulation was applied to the input
clip
for example a clip is cut into three
parts and permutated the network was
trained to predict which permutation was
applied among the six possible choices
the third type of pretext tasks are
contrastive learning based
in contrastive learning we have the
freedom to define positive and negative
samples
for each characteristic that we want the
network to learn for example if we want
the network to learn shapes then all the
objects with the same shape
are treated as positive samples
regardless of their size color or
texture
in image
pre-training a dominant pre-text task is
called instance discrimination
two patches drawn from the same image
are treated as positive samples and
patches from different images and active
samples
recently some researchers applied this
instance discrimination task to video
pre-training and achieved pretty good
results
unsurprisingly one could design a
multi-task pre-text by combining any two
or even all three types of the above
mentioned tasks
i'm not going into details
next i will talk about how we understand
this video pre-training problem and how
we tackle it
as we all know video is a type of highly
redundant data
what is the key information we want from
pre-training
recall that the purpose of pre-training
is to learn the features that downstream
tasks need while downstream tasks may
vary we first focus on the most widely
discussed task called action recognition
let's look at an example
this group of frames are drawn from a
sequence labeled as action shot
imagine you are provided only with the
first rgb frame and the two bounding
boxes indicating the location of an
athlete and the football
then in the subsequent frames only the
positions of the two bounding boxes are
provided
are you able to determine what actions
this video is about
i believe the answer is positive
so our idea is
if action can be recognized from object
location and trajectory then we just let
the network to learn object trajectories
during pre-training
this is
our recent work about vrl that published
in cvpr 2021 the code has been made
available on github
the pretext task we invented is called
catch the patch
the idea is to let the network learn
features which could efficiently predict
object trajectories
so the input to the network is a short
video clip and some query bounding boxes
in the first frame
the desired output is the location of
security boxes in all the subsequent
frames or trajectories
this pretext task is a prediction task
but it is different from the previous
ones where the supervision signal is
very easy to obtain
in this proposal the main challenge is
how to obtain the supervision signal
or the ground truth of object
trajectories
there are at least two ways to obtain
the ground choose trajectories one is to
employ modern object detectors and
trackers to detect salient objects in
the first frame and then track them down
in consequent frames
another way is to generate synthetic
data the first approach uses real data
but the labels might be noisy the second
approach has perfect ground-choose
trajectories but the data distribution
may deviate from the real data
we adopt the second approach but use a
mix-up idea to create fake videos that
look real
our method has three steps
in the first step we randomly crop a
patch from the first frame put it on a
blank canvas step 2 we move this patch
around according to a predefined
trajectory sometimes we even make it
disappear
step 3 we overlay the generated video
onto the original video to create the
mix-up video
we even try to crop up to 3 patches and
let them move independently on the
canvas
this method works very well
so we evaluate our pre-trained model in
the action recognition downstream task
and compare it with the models
pre-trained in annotation supervised
settings let's first look at the two
purple ovals
86.2 is the top one accuracy that our
model achieved on the ucf data set
ctp is the short name of our method
catch the patch
it is pre-trained on k-400 dataset
without using the labels
the accuracy achieved is much higher
than 79.5 which is achieved by a r3d
network inflated from a 2d network that
is pre-trained using the classification
task on imagenet
on the ucf dataset our method is not as
good as a supervised pre-training which
takes advantage of the action labels on
k-400 but on another heterogeneous data
set called something something our
method performs better showing a better
generalization capability than
supervised pre-training
the figure on the right emphasis the
importance of video proof training
in a downstream task with labeled data a
pre-trained model can make more
efficient use of the labels than
training from scratch
so now is a brief summary representation
learning is an important topic in
machine learning the paradigm of
pre-training plus fine tuning has been
widely accepted in solving deep learning
problems
in vil pre-text design they are huge
challenges
but their opportunities is even
is enormous so first of all pre-test
design is still an open problem because
instance discrimination task is still
not dominant in video pre-training
domain
second we conjecture that different
pre-text tasks are needed for different
groups of downstream tasks
and also video comes with multiple
modalities
in addition to the visual clues we also
have audios or speeches or even the text
that was translated from the audio so
making use of all the modalities and do
a cross-modality pre-training is also a
promising direction
this concludes my talk thank you very
much
i'm lou yan from cloud and air group i'm
glad to give the talk visual
representation learning with foundation
models
recently emerging ai systems based on
the foundation models are leading to
surprising progress for example gpt3 and
clip
in this talk we will demonstrate how to
build such foundation models to learn a
shareable visual representation from
broad data
the foundation model is based on an
optimal network architecture and self
surprise learning
and then the representation can be
adapted to a wide range of downstream
tasks including classification object
detection segmentation and so on
in such a three-layer ai system
transfer
learning makes the foundation models
possible where scale makes them powerful
next
we use some examples from our latest
work to demonstrate how to develop
financial models for visual
representation learning
we will talk about several key factors
like optimal architecture including
hierarchical vision transformer and
network architecture search
and the self-supervised learning for
fuel label transfer
following these key factors we further
talk about
the extension from global representation
to local representation learning when we
mention architecture designing
we want to recap two typical
architectures
one is transformer widely used in aop
another is cnn popular in computer
vision
which one is better
transformer consists of dynamic
attentions layer
and thus offers more capacities to fit
in with massive and various data
it refuses global context from the early
layers which captures the interaction
across different semantics and the
regions globally leading to a better
generalization
cnn learns multi-scale features by
multi-stage
the convolutional kernel is shift scale
and distortion invariant
it offers better modeling of local
special structure
so we have to ask ourselves a question
can we bridge two worlds together and
develop a new elegant and fused
architectures
we call the new architecture as a
hierarchical vision transformer
here we use our reason the convolutional
vision transformer as an example
on one hand it is hierarchical structure
as well as cnn and uses multi-stage
in each stage it consists of multiple
attention layers as well as the
transformer
on the other hand it maintains the grid
structure locally by incorporating
convolution into transformer layers
after filling both structures together
it can more easily capture the
relationship between nearby tokens while
keeping the ability to model global
information
meanwhile some similar architectures
like a swing vision non-firmer c-suite
and the focal transformer emerged and
demonstrate its remarkable improvement
over the linear vision transformer and
the cnn models in diverse vision tasks
here we show some key results
on the right side table
we show cvt performance much better than
strong cnn model bit and the vision
transformer when this large-scale
pre-training model
are transferred to classification
downstream tasks
on the left figure we show the cvt
achieves consistently better accuracy
than other concurrent works with
different model size
we're curious about if the manually
designed cvt is optimal structures or
not
a more amazing sense
if cvt with nas denoted by the star
can get much better performance
in terms of model size and quality
how do we achieve it
a part of modernized ai systems
nas technology can reduce the time in
model developing and the lower
uncertainty
model design and optimization can be
done automatically by machine learning
search the best architecture in the
whole model space is mp heart problem
we solve this problem with two steps
dampening a small portion of
architectural performance pairs and fit
in a proxy accuracy predictor
we seek
a progressive line of weak predictors
that can connect a path to the best
architecture
thus greatly simplifying the learning
tasks of each predictor
by cost to find iteration
our framework can find the optimal
architectures
eventually
as a result the search optimal cvt model
achieved higher classification accuracy
with lower flops and parameters than cvt
baseline
when we get close up to two
architectures
nas helps find the common design
principle for us
like the bottleneck of designing and
prefer more dimensions for projection
layers
nas framework has become
indispensable to build foundation models
the demand of
in labels
is another issue to potentially block
the large scale pre-training
self-surprise learning or unsupervised
learning is making significant progress
currently
there is still performance gap between
unsupervised learning and supervised
learning in transferring to downstream
tasks
the illustration shows the comparison
between the future clustering of target
data after applying the lina unsurprised
the model and the surprising model
respectively
every cluster cannot be isolated from
each other by unsurprising learning
compared with surprise learning
our recently study shows
improving unsurprised learning by
transductively can lead to better fuel
label transfer
which is critical
to generalization
we modify
the pre-training and fine-tuning
workflow
in unsurprising pre-training we mix up
small portions of unlabeled targeted
data with massive unlabeled source data
in fine tuning we adopt an active
learning way to only label few target
samples
by this way we achieve much better
generalization in field label transfer
then velina unsupervised the
pre-training moko v2 and surprised the
pre-training bit
more gains achieved on field label
setting shown the right side of the
table
we would further demonstrate optimal
architecture and the self supervised
learning
in building financial models for local
arbitrary level representation learning
to achieve better object level
representation we will unify the object
detection head architecture called
dynamic head to make it scale aware
spatial avail and the task aware
simultaneously
given the feature pyramid achieved from
backbone
with them we decompose attention
mechanisms into three sequential
attention modules
a skill aware tension along the pyramid
levels
special aware attention along the 2d
special location x y axis
and the tasks are well attention along
feature channels
compared with full attention used in
transformer layers
such decoupled attentions used in
dynamic head can be more efficient for
learning
this new dynamic head can achieve much
better generalization
and consistently improve any kind of
object detection framework as a plug-in
module
besides when pre-trained or more data
with the pseudo-bounding box
and the self-learning
it achieved single model city of art in
the ms koch benchmark
it pushes forward the success of
building financial models
for a global representation learning
towards local representation learning
as a summary visual representation
learning benefits from foundation models
trend from big data
with advanced and optimized architecture
and the self-supervised learning for
better transfer
three key factors help extend its
capabilities from global representation
to local representation we are which
will offer a unified stack to serve a
wide range of computer vision tasks
okay thanks for my talk
you